[Music]
things are never gonna be the same now I
mean look at this got aliens you got big
green guys turns out buildings as a kid
I used to draw cowboys and Indians um
actually it's Native American yeah
tell you what though they're bad is it
no yeah kids got a future
[Music]
nope hey you can't solve through that
stuff these alien bastards it tough you
got to use the stuff they use to join us
afternoon my llama bingo yeah yeah yeah
your lunch look just go smack that armor
plating like I asked this is a huge deal
for us
ten-chan please in accordance with
executive order two three nine six be
all post-battle cleanup operations are
now under Howard jurisdiction thank you
for your service we'll take it from here
well how are you qualified enough look I
have a city contract to salvage all this
okay with the city so apologize mr.
tooms but all salvage operations are now
under our jurisdiction please turn over
any and all exotic materials that you've
collected or you will be prosecuted man
my trucks for this job I don't know no
crew these guys have family I have a
face my house I'm sorry sir there's
nothing I can do
maybe next time don't overextend
yourself what you say yeah
he's right i overextended myself put him
down if you have a grievance you may
take it up with my superiors this
appears
booth Alan a joint venture between Stark
Industries in the federal government the
Department of damage control will
oversee the collection and storage of
alien and other exotic materials so not
[ __ ] will make this mess again pay
to clean it up yeah it's alright experts
estimate there are over 1500 tons of
exotic materials scattered throughout
the tri-state area hey chief we just
love another load from yesterday you're
supposed to turn this in right oh you
know Lynn it it's too bad
could have made some pretty cool stuff
from all that alien junk I'd say what
let's keep it
world's changing
[Music]
it's time we change too
[Music]
there you go Mason business is good
[Music]
New York Queens
it's a rough pour over hey its own be
talking to no one just making a little
video of the trip no you can't show it
to anyone ya know the more you narrating
in that voice yeah cuz it's for fun so
what they call you happy come on I'm not
carrying your bags go hey should I go to
the bathroom before there's a bathroom
on it
whoa no pilot that's awesome there we
gonna sit yeah is your first time I
private plane what's on anything should
I should have you should have been
making the noise
no one has actually told me why I'm in
Berlin or what I'm doing something about
Captain America going crazy this is your
public neighbors we're not roommates
okay what the hell are you wearing
it's my suit where's the case okay
that's not what I thought that was a
closet this is still Margaux please my
room is way bigger than that yeah I
found the case I found the case you
found the case a minor upgrade oh my god
put it on what this is the coolest thing
ever [ __ ] let's go I don't understand is
it for me
happy happy wait this is insane insane
look at this thing look look at the I
miss your greatest day my life okay I
gotta go I gotta go
okay the previous thing just happen
right let's never fight with Captain
America and I stole this shielding I
threw it at him he's big now I got
amazing things never happen see mr.
Stokes like a ruse and I just sort of
flipped in and I still kept sheila's
okay what's up everybody
and hey just a second coming hey there
thin walls here what is it a little
video diary
sorry I chose not to do it he was
filming everything I'm gonna run away to
chip you know we should actually we
should make an alibi a video for their
hand anyways ready hey how you doing
what are you wearing something skimpy I
hope that's inappropriate all right
let's start over we can edit it three
hey Mei my gosh I want to tell you what
a incredible job
your nephew did this weekend at the
Stork internship retreat everyone was
impressed it's a frigging merger so this
is cuz you're not in Queens bummer see
happiest is hoping to get bumped up to
asset management he was four head of
security and before that it was just a
drivers of private conversation
I don't like joking about this it was
hard for me to talk to them no seriously
was he snored about alright happy can
you give us a moment you want me to
leave grab Peters case out of the
trumpet I can keep the suit yes we were
just talking about do me a favor though
Happy's kind of your point guy in this
dos três amount don't do anything stupid
I've seen his cardiogram alright yes
don't do anything I would do and
definitely don't do anything I wouldn't
do
there's a there's a little gray area in
there and that's where you operate what
does that mean then I'm gonna venture
though that 7th floor I can take that up
you don't have to say you're gonna take
it oh yeah I could say thank you
she wins wins our next step was our next
retreat you know what next mission yeah
in the mission emissions we'll call you
do you have my number no I mean we'll
call you like someone will call you oh
all right 15
that's not a hug and just grabbing the
door for you we're not there yet bye
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
finally here we go good evening Peter oh
you have 576 possible well shooter from
the nation I can keep that suit yeah son
fit me what is the next retreat
what next mission we'll call you all
right it's not a hug them to scram the
top for you all right there yet all
right good good luck out there
you going tonight I can't tonight I got
the stark internship what's up guys
here's my report for tonight I stopped a
glance that bicycle hey could you do me
a favor hold on I helped us the old lady
and she bought me a churro
so how was nice you guys are the real
Avengers hope gives it away crazy
dangerous
listen fear of people who handle this
sort of thing can't you just be a
friendly neighborhood spider-man
activating parachute
the world's changing boys it's time we
change to my chest
prove myself we have a Spanish quiz you
gotta get better at this part of the job
what are you hiding
Peter I'm just getting hungry bye
there's a ton of other social systems in
here but we're all disabled by the
training wheels protocol treating me
like a kid
but you are a kid yeah stop a boss with
his bare hands
[Music]
and